did it bother you the Monique in making
trying to make her point kind of dragged
you in and every time she was talking
about what Netflix was paying her she
kind of you became the example that's a
good question thank you that's your
first ever I've had quite that point
yeah what about my question I I really
like Monique and I've like I think she's
so funny and and at first I was yeah I
did feel like kind of bummed that she
invokes my name and it was like I you
know my my special was shot and
negotiated so long ago it's not like I
negotiated it like okay and by giving me
this you promise you won't give Monique
more you know like but then she later
went on like you know said that she
didn't have any ill-will toward me and
it wasn't that she did so like it was it
was disappointing to me at first just
because I'm such a fan of hers um but
then I understood later yeah and it's
just a matter of look if you're putting
if people coming to see you of course we
have to wrap up a minute to boiler but
they're there uh you know they're gonna
give you money based on that that's all
Netflix gives a [ __ ] about is right who
they think is gonna make them the most
money yeah they're not like I like you
they're crunching numbers blink an eye
yeah